hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play nothing's in the night okay I
got over myself
I'm still going strong
okay I don't think there was anything in
this room do I have I don't have the
chisel but I'm assuming that I will get
that later well I don't even remember oh
yeah I need why that's the door that
someone was breathing from scream I'm
out of it screw that
everything about that can go screw
itself cuz I'm not dealing with that
let's blow this beast it's baloney it's
a closet Kate it's the closet kay this
says fourth floor closet this is the
closet Kate are you seeing this
are you seeing this you see this
ah okay whatever whatever whatever
whatever
I must have missed something back there
maybe it was closet as in one of the
cabinets
I don't know I don't know I don't know
I'm just gonna keep it go that was this
you gross everywhere gross okay okay
screw that maybe these closets which
seem to be precariously locked yes I was
right
chisel bingo gimme
I don't have it anymore haha oh okay I'm
out of here screw this and screw you
screw you all to hack
I'm out here I'm out of here I'm not
here I'm out of here
oh man I'm glad I didn't just go in that
thing that I exploit it through I'm glad
I just went through it I'm gonna see if
it just works on this no okay all right
whatever
let me have to come back there I don't
know I'm out here I'm out of here I'm
out of here I'm out of here I'm out of
here I'm out of here I'm out of here
I'm out of here I know I'm just I'm gone
I'm going I'm I'm already gone
I'm just aren't I
okay I'm fine let's flash okay
doing good on oil went better than I
thought I would be doing god I get
started didn't I
seems like it's all running together
okay I'm gonna do this the right way
totes legit totes Maggie Kent going
pretty cake bring broke dick Tom I don't
even get them back I could have gone
through your hat chisel buzzes leaver
sorts come on go to down there no okay
that started that not sure what that did
what did that do
I'm super curious because I don't
remember right I don't remember anything
mentioning anything about machinery that
I needed to turn on was there was there
a note about machinery that I needed to
turn on no I don't think so
yeah both these doors are like what was
the deal was um was this all doing every
three let me through let me through rod
I gots to go around
it was nothing back here right
nope okay
very curious is why I needed to turn
this on I don't think there was really
an explanation for that repeatable
sanity restoration of it
I'm confess
anyway I'll head back up cuz obviously I
was supposed to turn the machinery on
for some reason don't know what but I
gots it I gots it I don't even remember
being there being another door or
anything I just think it was like just
this that fourth floor door that I
haven't gone in and nothing really
right I don't think there was I when
that safe right out through there it's
all squishy in here and dead the only
thing left upstairs was that fourth
floor so let me check that out
and I think I might need to check the
third quartered floor again because I
kind of went through that a bit quick
I'm wondering if I might have missed
something I probably did man you'd think
after some people started no okay
nothing could have happened when I broke
down the door but there have been not
exactly sure
I don't know what I need to do let me go
looking again in here because I did I
did kind of skip through this and there
was that room where I went in and it was
just scare and I didn't see anything
else okay that's the door with the bar
behind it this is a dead end
oh there's oil I passed that right by
okay
it's been a particularly rough string of
episodes as you all can imagine I'm sure
you all are loving it and so on alright
so turned on some mystery machine some
mystery machine in the basement I don't
even remember why I needed to do that
well I needed is I needed to go get a
hammer and chipper to go down there and
get it and then but why did I need to go
about in basement in the first place
that's a question all I know is that
there was a note saying someone was
stuffing bodies down there and that's
about it
okay come on Oh
I don't think there's anything I left in
here for me there was this other closet
that seemed to be locked but if I tried
to use the key on this one I mean what
would have happened instead of oil again
I don't know that's not the door that
was a wall this one's still locked
there's so many unopened doors kind of
throwing me off
I don't know I got a loss I did the
thing with the lever where it kind of
went dun dun dun dun da da da oh wait
that's the starter I don't know I'm I'm
thoroughly confused like what would have
happened if I use a closely for the
other one and what did that do in the
basement that I should probably know
about and why I never even got any
information about going to the basement
maybe if I go back in here maybe there's
something in here that needed to be
turned on or maybe in the map oh I know
Oh gah upstairs master bedroom the gates
on the windows gah that's it that's
totally it I'm an idiot I just know
didn't think of it haha [ __ ]
okay all right I'm an idiot
aah oh no I guess that was the last
survivor besides Sara hopefully Sara
needs to stay alive with her fine her
fine booty sorry highly inappropriate at
me in fact I haven't even seen her I'll
go that's disrespectful to women I'm
gonna just shut up a now no I'm not I
can't I knew it moving on
okay whatever I'm kind of you know
right now so it's been a bit of a hectic
few episodes so I'm a little out of it
there it's bound to be a key somewhere
here right excuse me please get your
naked dead body off of the books I need
to look for stuff
don't push me away not seeing anything
it's a bunch of these skulls why are
there so many skulls I've pretty much
stopped asking questions regards to the
decor of this house house castle
I'm confused
but why why did I do that
tell me why I'm still alive why am I
still alive I'm stuck that is cool
instead of an instant fall death its I'm
trying to escape and then monsters swarm
me
oh I'm back down here on the wall there
- okay whatever it doesn't matter
what does matter cuz it kind of sucks
time away but that was pretty cool I I
like that touch it's like this guy I
swear real subtle things and that's
something that probably 90% of the
people that play it would never
encounter because they wouldn't be as
dumb as me and they wouldn't fall in the
first place so whatever huh that's cool
good job man
okay one floor up and then I'm through
the window again but I'm still looking
for like a key or something I didn't
pick up anything in there so I don't
know what the deal is
there's got to be something that I'm
missing him I mean what else is the
point over there was that was there
something on the windows oh I know
you're all like don't be jumping too
much we know you're bad at jumping okay
here nothing under a book maybe I think
behind the naked guy
maybe these books are placed so that
they're hiding something could be
doesn't seem to be
maybe there's a pulley book summer wet
slap bonk no okay
[Music]
look like it I'm looking everywhere I'm
really really looking this time not that
I wasn't looking before but
ah yeah oh yeah there anything else
behind their skulls I knew there had to
be something with these skulls all that
one I should have known because it was
like a blood stain or something okay I'm
gonna assume there's nothing else but
Batman if you hadn't been really looking
good overlooked that but I guess you
know necessity would have told you that
there had to be something in that room
okay either way go into the fourth floor
actually no I'm not because I'm overtime
again so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye-bye